[Musik]
das sind so viele stellenanzeigen für
praktiker ich kann mich gar nicht
entscheiden
okay zum beispiel hier zuverlässiger
zielorientiert und flexible praktikantin
im bereich grafikdesign junges
motiviertes team sucht verstärkung du
willst erfahrungen sammeln und hass
interesse an design
dann schick uns deine bewerbung an und
so weiter so seine anzeige für ein
praktikum im bereich grafikdesign
ich weiß nicht genau aber ich finde dass
ich das gut anhört eine stellenanzeige
von einem architekturbüro die suchen
auch praktikanten ruft ja aber ich weiß
nicht ob ich das kann hier zuverlässige
kreative praktikantin im mit dem
schwester ich ach so ich über nur ein
paar sätze für einen bewerbungsgespräch
du schaffst das hilft mir beim essen ja
ich komme gleich
ich muss schluss machen und du schreibst
die bewerbung für die schauspielschule
ich weiß nicht ich wollte doch die
ausbildung zum zweirad kannst du ja
trotzdem du sollst es wenigstens
versuchen
[Musik]